>> LAST TUESDAY THE SUPREME
COURT HEARD ORAL ARGUMENTS
ON SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
THE OPPONENTS CAME OUT IN
FORCE.
>> AMERICA'S PREVERSIONS ARE
GROWING EXPONENTIALLY.
>> WE BELIEVE AS MY SIGN
SAYS THAT HOMOSEXUALITY IS A
THREAT TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> OUR COUNTRY GROWS DARKER
AND EVILER BY THE DAY.
>> AH, GOOD TIMES.
BUT WITH THE SUPREME COURT
LIKELY RULING IN FAVOR OF
GAVE MARRIAGE, CHANCES ARE
THIS WOULD BE THE LAST HURRAH
FOR THE HATE CLASS OF 2015.
BEFORE THEY MOVED ON TO THE
REAL WORLD, I WANTED TO
COMMEMORATE
THEM.
>> SO COULD YOU SIGN THIS FOR ME
PLEASE?
>> SURE. YOU GOT IT. THERE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH. PROMISE
WE'LL HANG OUT IN TEN YEARS.
>> PROMISE.
>> WHO WOULD YOU VOTE
MOST LIKELY TO SUCCEED OTHER
THAN THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPORTING GAY MARRIAGE?
>> UM --
>> YOU'RE DEFINITELY BEST
DRESSED.
>> THIS IS MY UNIFORM.
>> DON'T FEEL PRIDE, THE BAR
IS REALLY LOW, IT'S REALLY LOW,
THERE ARE LITERALLY NO GAY
PEOPLE TO HELP YOU OUT.
DID YOU GOOGLE THIS
IMAGE?
>> IT'S A WITNESSING TOOL OF THE
TRUTH OF WHAT IS GOING ON, THAT
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SEE.
>> I'M GOING TO MISS THAT
JUSTIFICATION FOR YOU
GOOGLING TWO MEN KISSING --
WHO WOULD YOU SAY IS
LIKE MOST OUTGOING?
>> MOST OUTGOING?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> BROTHER RUBEN ISREAL.
>> RUBEN ISRAEL WOULD BE THE
FUNNEST GUY, YOU NEED TO
TALK TO HIM.
>> RUBEN ISRAEL.
>> WOW, EVERYBODY IS TALKING
ABOUT RUBEN ISRAEL, HE'S
LIKE THE POPULAR GUY ON CAMPUS.
>> HE'S NOT REAL POPULAR
WITH THE GAY COMMUNITY BUT
HE IS POPULAR WITH THE STREET
PREACHERS--
>> OF COURSE, THERE WAS NO WAY I
WOULD GET TO TALK
TO THIS BIG MAN ON CAMPUS UNTIL
IT HAPPENED.
I MET MR. CHARISMA HIMSELF.
CAN I GET A HUG?
>> NO. WHY WOULD I WANT TO HUG
YOU.
THERE ARE A LOT OF LESBIANS
AROUND HERE YOU CAN HUG.
YOU SHOULD HAVE READ THE BIBLE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE TURNED TO GOD
AND THE BIBLE.
>> I CAN SEE WHY HE IS SO
POPULAR.
>> IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THIS
MIGHT ALL BE COMING TO AN
END.
I'M SO, JUST REALLY GOING
TO MISS THIS.
THIS IS THE LAST TIME THAT I
WILL BE ABLE TO HANG OUT
WITH THESE ADOREABLE BIGOTS.
CAN YOU HOLD ME?
>> NO.
>> NO? IS IT A LITTLE TOO GAY?
I JUST-- LOVE THE WAY YOU
GUYS PROTEST OVER SOMETHING
THAT IS LIKE NOT EVEN AN
ISSUE ANY MORE.
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE YOUR HAT
OFF AND THROW IT IN THE AIR.
>> NO, I'M OKAY. I WILL LEAVE IT
RIGHT WHERE IT IS SO EVERYBODY
CAN READ IT.
>> THE TEARS WERE FLOWING.
I'M GOING TO MISS YOU GUYS.
>> DON'T WORRY YOU'LL HAVE
PLENTY OF SIN TO CRY ABOUT.
AND YOU WILL SEE US PLENTY OF
TIMES.
>> OKAY, THANKS, OLD FRIEND.
I'LL DRY MY EYES TO THAT.
YOU WANT A TISSUE?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO CRY WHEN MY
GOD PUT YOU IN HELL, EITHER.
NO TEARS FROM ME.
>> I'M GOING TO MISS THAT.
>> YES, YOU ARE.